my name is Alex tatarskiy I used to be
an iOS developer from iOS for something
like that and then I joined Facebook
where they taught me how to use HTML CSS
and JavaScript to build web apps so I
did that for a while and then react came
out and I was blown away I I completely
fell in love with this framework I knew
it's going to be big like it was such a
huge shape that I was really excited
about so I joined react native team and
I worked in there for like three years
focusing mostly on the developer
experience Facebook integrations and
stuff like that but I also really
enjoyed building apps with retina so
last year with both afraid app they will
open source to documented and it's
available out there and now I'm working
at Otto's helping them build some of
them about apps one of the react native
team the thing that was really exciting
to me is that we're giving you access to
all platform capabilities so if I just
using a simple web component you get
access to the real platform specific
components like us call view or scroll
view widget on Android this is the
phrase I've heard many many times from
different people at Facebook that medium
may need 10 times more productive so I
built this scientific drop explaining
this this time it takes to build it out
or build iOS app and then Android maybe
takes a little longer inject native is
like haben 10% a file
however I drag native user now I
understand that after 10% of time the
app is not done it's functional it's a
paradise it's real fun to play with and
see it real but it's not quite done and
it has to be has to deal with some
specifics of mobile platform it's just
that building for mobile platform is
different than building from for web and
I've seen the situation many many times
edge Facebook an outside space with
people from with web experience come
into react native ecosystem they see all
these components that seem very familiar
like it's really clear how to use these
things you know everything is react so
it's simple
they put this component inter mobile app
and
I happy about this and it's great
because they created something that
didn't exist before however if you put
this up through the brain machine
usually the results turns out like
something is wrong like you can't really
tell what but there is something that
just doesn't feel right
hopefully today I'm sure I'm going to
show you how to arrange some of these
components and configure it in the right
special way and using some knowledge and
some magic that will result in a good
outcome I'm going to talk to you about
these five things all these things are
super simple if you are expecting some
like groundbreaking you know information
it's like these things are very simple
but they are not obvious if you are
coming from web in the end I'm going to
share the main secret to build an
amazing app with that native but we're
starting with text input text inputs on
web is the thing that just works
Islamic form you put few inputs there
and everything is fine your computer has
a physical keyboard attached to it Tom
key facilities like fast switch between
those things and just works by default
your browser can autocomplete your email
address or password and stuff like that
this will convenient so let's say you're
building an Instagram login flow and you
want to create this form and there is
text input so your initial
implementation might look like this just
text input with some styles and handle
the input event
you put it on a simulator and it works
just fine you're tested you know
everything's great you can log in great
however running the same app on a mobile
device will give you a completely
different experience it just it's going
to be somewhat clunky and want to feel
great and again this goes back to the
fact that just spending 10% of the time
doesn't mean the app is completely done
so if you look at the mobile development
and all the all these little details you
will notice that usually you want to
outer focus the first
- very user extra top you wanna use
placeholders to highlight what those
things are keyboard is a software
keyboard so it occupies space on the
screen so you have to care and be
careful not to cover important elements
like a log in with Facebook button here
you have to know how to dismiss keyboard
how to configure each text input to you
know use or not use spell checking out
the capitalization you can customize
keyboard type tool for example make it
easier to enter email addresses and you
can also program this return key that
can do whatever you want so again back
to the code that native actually gives
you the full power of all platforms at
you to your disposal so you can you know
configure it precisely the way it must
be like select any keyboard appearance
placeholders outer part or
capitalization outer correct keyboard
type return key program the return key
this means the key etc wow this might
seem overwhelming and it is because your
head is provided the full power and you
can easily abstract this away in your
company specific email input that does
everything right and hide this
complexity coming up next is direct
manipulation what I mean by that is that
when you have a mouse attached to a
computer you directly manipulating this
piece of hardware and this piece of
power is connected to a thing on the
screen which is a cursor and cursor is
great it's very precise it's pixel
perfect it shows you feedback when
something is actionable or editable it
also tells you one we can do is be be
doing some stuff and won't accept your
inputs well it all goes out of the
window when you go to mobile devices and
the way touchscreen works is that it
creates this illusion of direct
manipulation instead of having at this
upon layer that connects to a pointer
you directly manipulated stuff on your
screen and this has four main
implications first we need instant
feedback
imagine you have a notebook and
ten and you start driving something but
there is a delay between you do
something and you see a line appear on
the paper it was so very weird junkie
and you know after some time it is just
unusable well to result on mobile
devices mobile browsers at 350
milliseconds delay to each tab
interaction and there are good reasons
they do that but I think that
contributes a lot to the perception of
mobile being slow on where Canadians use
all the touchable things that you can
wrap your components and they usually do
the right thing so definitely use them
next up physics again another example
you have a basketball basketball ball
and you drop it on the floor and it
slides like this and the dunce doesn't
bounce back again something is really
fishy here it just still drawn so when
you are building animations with rekha
native make sure that you customize
those things to simulate real physical
processes not just some random values
that kind of look good something that
feels good Big Shot out here too weak
for building react native instructable
this thing is basically physics engine
running on your phone with access to
direct media that you can use to program
your stuff this is where the 60fps is
really important like when you drop a
frame this great the illusion of direct
manipulation and that creates this
feeling of junky mess and not feeling
right again rec native provides this use
native driver thing that you should use
to make sure that all animations are not
stopped by JavaScript also there is
interaction manager module that you can
use to coordinate your complex
computations and to not interrupt touch
and animations next up touch targets so
imagine you have this up and you want to
tap the search icon it's actually so
small I'm not sure you in the back
series but and user fingers are pretty
big for the screen it's really hard to
you know sit directly on that icon so
the way mobile platforms
I work on this issue is that they make
the top target of the items and burns
much larger than they appear so this is
example from Google material design
where the top target is four times as
big as the item itself react native
supports all of that you can set in
slope when you touch touchable component
to make sure that they're easily
accessible that native also ships with a
touchable inspector so if you turn on an
inspector in this option it will
highlight all touchable with their ships
load so you can see directly how big
they are and last but not least ability
to cancel interactions this is a very
complex topic
I need like deserves definitely a
separate talk I'm just going to show you
one example of how this works for by
default for the balance so when you push
the button
but slide away and release the top is
canceled so this ability of canceling
your direct manipulation is really
important the ability to like go back or
cancel whatever you doing if you are
building your custom gestures this is
really really important
coming up next animation in spatial
awareness as human beings we evolve in
three-dimensional space and we have this
feeling of things around us so for
example I don't see the screen behind me
but I still know it's there we use this
concept in the desktop a lot so for
example I have two folders on my desktop
and if they're getting covered by some
window like Spotify I still know they're
there they under the window which is a
ridiculous thing because the UI is
two-dimensional but we have this like
spatial awareness still built in however
all desktop applications they have the
luxury of running on the large screen
the same abstraction will just not work
for mobile it is just not enough space
and we're not good at seeing tiny little
details so the way it works and Mobile
is the apps pretend to have a much
larger surface than you can see on the
screen so for example in the same
it pretends that aesthetically it is big
much bigger than the screen and it lets
users manipulate this list to see only
the parapet but it's not only about the
scrolling so here is animations that are
used on iOS when you open up a folder so
close them you see where the apps coming
from and where they go on and really the
concept of shared element transition
where the same element appears on both
screens and it gives you kind of the
feeling of where things are where they
moving and the point of all this is that
animation is not a luxury this is not
something you sprinkle on top of your
averages make it so great animation is a
vital tool for establishing spatial
awareness
another thing that facilitates the
spatial awareness is the ability to go
back on iOS swipe is usually used to go
back or the back button that is in top
left Android is slightly different they
have what they call a hardware back
button that is not Hardware anymore but
it's still there and users have very
specific expectations of what this
button does and what it should do to
your up here is an example of the chain
react app and it's a great app and like
the world is much better with this
update without it it's just that it has
one of these small details let's say you
are expending a map view and then
pressing back it takes you back to the
first tab even though the expectations
for Android user is to collapse them up
back it's like a subtle detail and you
would expect it you know to behave one
way and then it behaves the other way
and it just stops a little wrong so
those little details they matter a lot
next up loaded state so whether it's
mostly about the pages of content this
is to act native web documentation page
and I'm just going to start load-in it
so I should enter the URL bar I see
something coming up on this
screen and then items Lord fun flawed
some more content Lords and it was okay
but for the web it's great it's just
normal
it's it matches your expectations of web
however on mobile it's more nuanced so
let's say you have this up where you
have list of tasks and the topic details
and you want to transition from one to
another
your initial naive implementation will
be something like this you'll create a
component that takes the task ID and
when this component is mounted you fetch
the task detail and while this is
special you are showing their activity
indicator because literally you don't
have any data to put on the screen and
it looks like this you tap something and
it's loading on the full screen in your
app is basically empty for some time and
then join and and the experience is met
it's functional it's great that you know
you will we were able to do this in
short time but the resulting experience
is just not awesome if you look at other
examples of this and how it's done right
on face book out for example when you
tap a profile you get profile
information right away it looks like
magic and it took me some time to figure
out what's going on but it actually make
sense so the way they do it if you
wanted those two screams a lot of data
is actually shared like task owner title
priority and stuff like that already
known to the list so what we can do is
we can pass these details as an object
to the detailed view and then render it
before the data comes back so we have
something to show and in this content is
enough to render at least first half of
the clean the transition will fill
instant another called detail would do
is we could start loading the data even
before the touch actually happened on
the touch star demand and this is really
cool this symbolize after 500
milliseconds of you know animating
prochaine animating again and by the
time if your server is good you will
receive the response and it will fill
instance the way I like to think about
these things is
you're kind of training some developer
experience for the user experience you
have to go out of your comfort zone and
maybe use some frameworks in a way that
wasn't intended but the result is much
better user experience back to the
million dollar question which library
should use I think the point of my talk
is that it doesn't matter as a direct
native developer I spent three years
building regular and I would hate for
people to come in and be limited by the
framework don't compromise your user
experience by the frameworks you choose
if something doesn't pick your ideal
image of the app just like go around it
extended and so for UI library so a
paragraph some people to build Facebook
standard components in their native for
other people to use and they came back
with this like building with retina is
so easy
we don't need standard components and
it's it sounds appealing like if you
look at the button implementation of it
could be very simple it's just touchable
opacity with some text it sounds really
cool simple again it's 10% of the time
doesn't mean it's hundred percent done
think about cross-platform how this
button looks on different platforms
what about disabled state items fixes
height and heat slope text wrapping
accessibility and consistency with other
controls those things are real hard to
get tried so the we will recommend using
or building your own standard controls
and for companies like Facebook they
will then be and others will already
build our own libraries of components
that other people use the beauty of this
approach is that very well designed and
build basic components which is so much
easier to build amazing apps all these
little details just work fine
and all you need to do is compose them
in the right way so we're just about all
these five things what they have in
common is to see them you have to
experience it on the real device you
have to run your app not only similar
the rural iPhone or Android animations
and gears are essential tools they're
not watching and sometimes you have to
go beyond what frameworks provide guides
maybe some native code or use something
that is not considered good practice in
relax all of these things I talked about
they're not rocket science in fact you
don't even need a human-computer
interaction degree to understand those
things they're simple however I was
looking for resources on that and I
couldn't find some I think the reason is
partially because this knowledge is
built into the experience of native
developers for them its nature like they
know these things even without realizing
they're an ornament but if you are
coming from web it might be a little bit
challenging to like get all the things
right so grant and I are added in this
new section to react native the
communication that we'll have always
small snippets a little detail feel free
to contribute to that as well but most
importantly you have to learn to see
these things you can read about all this
for a long time but just start noticing
it it will come a current and you will
once you learn to see it it's going to
be much much easier so back to the main
secret of building amazing apps would be
that leader is you have to care you have
to care about user experience deeply
truly care and this slide doesn't have
designers have to care because if you
look at the designer tools they actually
great for drawing dead fish definitely
look at a breath Victor stock he argues
that August two-dimensional flat things
they are frozen in time they're not
interactable it's really hard to design
proper user experience with just these
tools all these little details I talked
about that should be they contribute to
the quality and this quality is our
responsibility
the developers are responsible for the
quality of the app not designers not the
users not the peer
it's important because quality defines
different sessions our businesses
imagine Twitter apps being a very city
up nobody would use it and Twitter will
go down like it's very important for
your business value to have amazing our
presence but what's even more
interesting and important for this
conference is that the quality of the
apps we build with react native defines
the perception of your native ecosystem
at the fall so as the magnet of
developers and contributors I'd like us
to focus on building the pit of success
we need to build this little detail into
the basic component so that the default
way is the right way so it's easier to
build amazing experiences we also need
to talk more about us so if you are
preparing the conference submitting a
talk or doing the read native training
include some stuff about user experience
into your materials and we need more
great examples of the apps build with
attention to detail so on the second
floor is a coffee station I'm going to
hang out here there if you have any
questions with that thank you very much
[Applause]